thank you all very much for coming
welcome to this panel lecture in
celebration of the 80th anniversary of
the oxford english dictionary I'm Alice
Paris car I'm the Yale University
librarian and I'm very proud that the
library is sponsoring this event we also
thank Oxford University Press most
warmly for proposing and assisting to
use in sponsoring this birthday party
and for arranging to have our very
special guests with us tonight and I
know that the press will be delighted
with witness this turnout the OED is the
foundation on which any good reference
collection rests and a search in Orbis
the Yale library catalog for Oxford
English Dictionary reveals some 37
records with many more specific Holdings
including compact paperback concise
compact discs and online versions not to
mention the massive 20 volume set that
so many of us are familiar with so many
of us love and perhaps quite a few of us
even have on our shelves at home I want
to introduce our moderator fridge to
Pierrot and he is then going to
introduce the panel and we'll begin
tonight's symposium pred our Shapiro is
associate librarian for collections and
access and lecturer in legal research at
Yale Law School his books include the
Yale book of quotations that had some
volume with the huge queue on the front
published by Yale University Press and
the Oxford Dictionary of American Legal
quotations and a trial-and-error an
oxford anthology of legal stories which
he published with Jane Geary both
published by Oxford University Press
the Yale book of quotations published by
Yale has won many awards and was
favorably reviewed in The New Yorker The
New York Times and The Times of London
recently named by the Wall Street
Journal as the number two essential
reference book I don't know which
One World Almanac to some extent the
Yale book of quotations is the oxford
english dictionary of quotations
applying the techniques used by the OED
two quotes for the first time but with a
strong American slant
fred has won been one of the great
contributors to the OED since 1978 and
was the first to use full-text online
databases for linguistic research John
Simpson chief editor of the OED
wrote in the OED news in 2002 old friend
Fred Shapiro at Yale must have sent a
valuable suggestion for almost every
entry in the book which is probably a
bit like reading the entire book but we
will no doubt hear a lot more about that
well thank you again for coming to you
join us with this event please but the
end of a symposium do join us for a
reception in the Sterling Memorial
Library and we look forward very much to
seeing all of you there and meanwhile
I'm very happy to hand over to Fred and
are immensely distinguished panel
Thank You Alice it's a tremendous
privilege to moderate this event
commemorating the 80th anniversary of
the OED
I consider the OED to be the greatest
humanistic research project in the world
it sheds light on language history
culture science as nothing else does and
I like the fact that the OED is Janus
faced its forward-looking it uses
technology quite a bit I believe the XML
markup language was developed because of
the computerization of the OED but it's
also backward looking and I mean that in
the good sense that they're among the
few people nowadays that are preserving
certain scholarly virtues such as
verifying information in the original
sources which the OED does religiously
and it's also a privilege to moderate
because if we have three wonderful
panelists here I'll introduce them and
then I'll say a talk a little bit about
connections between the OED and Yale
Ammon Shea has been reading dictionary
since he was 10 years old along the way
he supported this habit by being a
street musician in Paris a gondolier in
San Diego and a furniture mover in New
York City and he has written a book
about this habit of reading dictionaries
which just came out called reading the
OED one man one year twenty one thousand
seven hundred and thirty pages it's
published by penguin and he's authored a
previous book about obscure words called
depraved and insulting English he lives
in New York with his girlfriend a former
lexicographer and a large number of old
dictionaries our second panelist is
Jesse shied Laur and any of you who
listen to NPR have heard Jesse probably
thousands of times
he's very frequently on NPR he's
editor-at-large of the Oxford English
Dictionary focusing on North American
usage and he's also an expert on slang
he was a project editor for the
historical dictionary of American slang
which is another great great historical
dictionary he's probably most famous to
the general public for his book the
f-word which there's an entire book
setting forth the history of the f-word
and all its derivatives published by
Random House in 1995 he has an
undergraduate degree in English from
University of Chicago the graduate work
at Cambridge in the department of
anglo-saxon Norse and Celtic and I
myself a fairly ignorant of technology
so this impresses me although not a
computer programmer by training
shallower introduced Perl to the North
American Offices of Oxford University
Press and developed tools for data
manipulation when no programmers were
available our third panelist is Simon
Winchester who has just a fascinating
background and list of books
he studied geology at Oxford before
working in Africa and on offshore oil
rigs
he had a 20 year career as a foreign
correspondent for The Guardian while
there he was a witness to the events of
Bloody Sunday in Ireland he was captured
as a journalist by the Argentinian
forces in the Falkland war and he was
played at BBC had a television drama
about the invasion in which he was
played by Paul Jeffrey his most recent
book is the man who loved China it just
came out this year about the British
biologist and Chinese scholar Joseph
Needham Simon's other books include a
number of these were major bestsellers a
crack in the edge of the world
America in the great California
earthquake of 1906 Krakatoa the day the
world exploded the meaning of everything
which is relevant here because it's
about the making of the OED the map that
changed the world
miss William Smith and the birth of
modern geology the surgeon of Crowther
on a tale of murder madness and the
making of the Oxford English Dictionary
which in the United States was called
professor and the madman I heard at one
point that there was gonna be a movie
made of it with Mel Gibson as James
Murray and Robin Williams Robin Williams
as dr. WC miner and I was very much
looking forward to that movie but I
suppose maybe Mel Gibson got too
involved with the passion of the christ'
but it's not it's now supposed to be the
chap that was in there will be blood
what was his name Daniel day-lewis
excellent well I'd certainly hope that
that does come out wonderful let me
before going on to the panelists
speaking let me just talk about
connections between the OED and yeah I
made up a list of some connections that
the big connection is that the man and
dr. W c-minor
attended Yale so he was a Yale graduate
another connection is that the book
caught in the web of words which is a
wonderful book by James Murray's
grandeur James Murray for those of you
that don't know was the original editor
of the OED and his granddaughter wrote a
magnificent biography of him called
caught in the web of words that was
published by Yale University Press and
two recent books about the OED were
published by Yale University Press one
is treasure house of the language and
one is called losses for words
another connection is that the OED as
part of their commitment to checking
original sources for all their citations
or the citations that are first uses
they have library researchers at the
major libraries of the world so they
have library researchers at Oxford
London Cambridge Massachusetts New York
Washington DC and New Haven because of
the greatness of the Yale library and
Melinda Babcock who's in charge of the
library research for the OED emailed me
it said this might be a good time to
acknowledge the work of Jane Gary who
has carried out library research on
behalf of the OED for the past five
years
we very much appreciate the support of
the Yale University Libraries
particularly the by Nicki and law
libraries and she just mentioned those
two libraries but Jane Gary and her
library research for the OED extensively
uses the Sterling library and the
medical historical library in the best
library and the divinity library and the
client Science Library and really all
the libraries at yeah then john simpson
the chief heir of the OED when I asked
him for connections with Yale he said he
pointed out that Yale was one of the
first institutions to subscribe to the
OED online when that came out I I guess
the final connection as I also mentioned
is that I'm a contributor to the OED it
might I'm not as colorful as W C minor
but there was a little thoughtfulness to
how I got into consuming to the OED when
I was in college I was on the MIT
tiddlywinks team and then I went on to
law school and I was completely bored by
law school and I did everything except
my law studies when I so I continued
with tiddlywinks and I became the
official historian of the North American
tiddlywinks Association and I thought
that as part of my duties in this
position I should find that the origins
of the game of tiddlywinks which turned
out was not not really no so I went to
the reference collection at the Widener
Library a car
another very great library and I saw it
the OED and I believe this is the only
time that this was the first time I had
ever used the OED and I looked up the
word tiddlywinks and their first use for
the word tiddlywinks was 1894 so then I
went from there to the basement of the
water library which has a nice or at
that time had a nice collection of old
books on sports and games and I found
about five books that talked about
tiddlywinks being around before 1894 so
I thought whoa you know what does this
mean how can they have something earlier
than the Oxford English Dictionary so a
friend of mine told me that the Oxford
English Dictionary was coming out with a
supplement at that time and that if I
wrote to them this was long before email
if I wrote to them they would probably
be interested in this information so I
wrote to the OED and I got a response
from one of their editors who said well
thank you for sending these five about
information about these five books
however you should understand that when
you look at a 1961 book and it says that
in 1883 two little old ladies went into
FAO Schwarz toy store and inquired about
tiddlywinks that doesn't really count as
an 1883 citation we have to have actual
contemporary dated documentation so
that's no good but they said of the five
I sent one of them was good because I
had found an 1890 book young folks
cyclopædia of sports and games which had
an article on tiddlywinks they said this
is is this is useful to us and we'll
keep it in our files till we get up to
the letter T twenty years from now so
it's you have to be into delayed
gratification if you're a nobody
contributor but I again I was looking
for things to do other than my law
studies so I was I looked at these a lot
of other of these old sports and games
books and I found there were other words
that I could find earlier uses than what
the OED had as their early excuse and I
started sending these to Oxford and at
first I was very very obnoxious I I
couldn't I was 24 years old at the time
I somehow couldn't deal with the fact
that the OED wasn't perfect of course it
would be impossible for them to read
every newspaper and book and publication
ever written in English language and get
every word in them but I thought somehow
that they did and and that there was
something was wrong here so finally
after a few months of these obnoxious
letters from the Bob birch field who was
the editor of the OED supplement stepped
in and wrote to me and said yes we see
that you're upset about this and that
we're always having people that write to
us that are upset about this and that
but we would appreciate if you would
please stop it but he you know he didn't
just say we don't we don't want to hear
from you go away I think he knew from
dealing with other obnoxious
contributors that you know there was a
slight chance that I might be worth
humoring so he didn't completely write
me off and I decided rather than you
know continue to be obnoxious that I
should just send in citations and be
helpful so I sent and I continued
sending a lot of citations over the
years more in the early 80s before I had
a job than later but I've sent a lot of
citations particularly auntie datings
earlier uses of words than their first
use and I think because of that I'm
probably one of the more significant
contributors because I focus on auntie
datings and the other thing I did that
was significant was that a few years
later still at law school I harbored
there was a new database that had come
out
called Lexus and I thought this database
has the full-text of legal cases back to
the 1800s you know what if I just typed
in words and it would tell me what was
the earliest use in these legal cases
maybe that would lead to an today ting
so the OED saw I went over to the law
library which I never otherwise
frequented and I stormed into a training
session a Lexus training session that
one of the librarians was given and I
said I started interrupts could you look
up a word for me and see what the
earliest uses so the librarian
also humored me like others had humored
me and I gave him the word mootness mo o
TN ESS the OE d's first use was 1946 but
he found in 1940 there was a case in
Lexus that had it so this I think was
the first use of online databases for
this kind of research and it was before
there even was a nexus which is the big
online database for for finding word
usages it came out a few years later and
a few years after that the OED started
very heavily using online databases and
now for probably virtually every word
they run it through a battery of
databases to find the earliest uses and
then the last thing I do in connection
with the OED is that I as Ellis
mentioned I published a quotation
dictionary a couple of years ago the
Yale book of quotations in which I tried
to some extent to apply an OE D model to
quotations where I found that the Oxford
Dictionary potations and Bartlett's
quotations were pretty reliable for
quotations with clear-cut origins to be
or not to be that is the question but
not very good for quotations without
clear-cut origins and so what I set out
to do is to use these same kinds of
research tools that I had used for words
for quotations to find the earliest use
I could find and that's what I put in
the book but rather than my going on let
me turn things over to our
much more talented panelists and it will
start with Simon Winchester Thank You
Fred very much um I thought what I do is
just to give a very simple and brief
historical overview how we came to the
beginnings of the of the OED that the
crucial for dates to remember it's the
one that we're celebrating at the moment
which is clearly 2008 - 80 so 1928 which
is when the first of the 12 vol new
English dictionary or Oxford English
dictionary's that came to be called was
published in in Oxford but the crucial
dates before that as 1604 1755 and 1857
and the interesting thing to me about
1604 when I started doing research for
when I was working on the professor and
the madman was an indication of how
modern dictionaries are for the 1604 was
really the first proper dictionary ever
created and it astonished me that there
hadn't been dictionaries way way before
that 1604 was the year that Shakespeare
wrote measure for measure 3/4 of the way
through his playwriting life and for
those many years he didn't have access
to a dictionary there was no such thing
the concept of looking something up that
phrase actually didn't appear in the
English language until 1692 and the
reason for this is that although
dictionaries strictly speaking had
existed for a very long time
they were always bilingual dictionaries
they were translating dictionaries
English into Latin or English into
German or French into Latin and so forth
the idea of an alphabetical list of
English words with their meanings
attached to them
never occurred to anyone to write I mean
there was the extraordinary gap in their
commercial - in the 17th century until
the 17th century there were one or two
books that were are for hearted attempts
to be dictionaries in that there were
pamphlets collections of words relating
to let's say there was a book of all
things that fly which included birds and
wasps and insects of one sort or another
and there were collections of words
relating to pieces of furniture but
nothing that was an attempt to put in
alphabetical order all kinds of words
from the English language until in 1604
a schoolmaster from Rutland
which is a county in the middle of
England where oddly enough I was this
morning came up with the idea of
preparing a dictionary alphabetical with
the meanings that it appended to the
words so that the people that move
through polite society could more easily
make intelligent sounding conversation
and the point of the the words he
selected if you remember at that time in
British history people dressed in a most
extravagant manner with Peri wigs and
ruffled blouses and strange sort of
velvet trousers and odd-looking shoes
when they spoke in a similarly
extravagant manner they used very
peculiar words generally known in these
days as inkhorn terms specifically to
impress one another although the words
themselves meant very little I mean
words like Bulbul suit 8:1 words man so
dressed would approach a woman and
suggest that perhaps they might like to
Bulbul sedate he didn't know what it
meant she didn't know what he meant
but it sounded impressive enough that
she probably did and mr. Cordry decided
to corral these words between hardcovers
and he prepared the first dictionary a
dictionary of hard and unusual words
designed for ladies gentle women and
other unskillful persons
despite the subtitle the book which went
on sale in the autumn of 1604 sold like
hotcakes everyone wanted to keep one of
these books in their inside pockets so
that at a social gathering they could
pull them out and surreptitiously say I
feel like an arch Graham ASEAN today or
something like that to impress people at
dinner or cocktail parties
so this forcing open of a commercial of
the commercial wedge that Corddry
achieved in 1604 produced during all of
the 17th century a veritable flood of
small dictionaries there were I think
2,000 words in his first and then there
was one with 5,000 words and then with
ten and by the end of that century the
dictionary was an established part of
English cultural life but it wasn't
until the middle of the next century the
18th century when a parliamentary sketch
writer and journalist Samuel Johnson
decided to write with a team of five
other Scotsman Goethe Scotsman the first
real dish made the first attempt to
pinion between hardcovers all the words
in the English language it took them
about six years to do it and the
dictionary that resulted two volumes
became for the next century rather more
than a century the dictionary that
graced the shelves of every intelligent
and educated persons household they
would have the Bible and they would have
Shakespeare and they would have
the dictionary and by the dictionary
they melt meant without a shadow of
doubt Johnson but Johnson he was a
peculiar man as I'm sure most of you
know and he was very cantankerous and
rhubarb ative and very politically
inclined and his definitions were in
many senses peculiar I mean the famous
one is his definition of the word oats
a grain commonly given to horses but
which in Scotland feeds the people but I
want to read you my favorite Johnson
definition not merely because it's a
beautiful thing to read but because it
illustrates what was bad what was
wanting in his dictionary and it's his
definition of the word elephant it can
be assumed safely I think that there
being no channel tunnel in 1755
elephants were rarely seen in Britain
and it's unlikely I think that Johnson
really ever saw one nonetheless he rose
to the task of defining elephant very
well the largest of all quadrupeds of
whose sagacity faithfulness prudence and
even understanding many surprising
relations are given the animal is not
carnivorous but feeds on hay herbs and
all sorts of pulse and it is said to be
extremely long life it is naturally very
gentle but when enraged no creature is
more terrible he is supplied with a
trunk or long hollow cartilage like a
large trumpet which hangs between his
teeth and serves him four hands by one
blow with this trunk he will kill a
camel or a horse and will raise a
prodigious weight with it his teeth of
the ivory so well known in Europe some
of which have been seen as large as a
man's five and a fathom in length wild
elephants are taken with the help of a
female ready for the male she is
confined to a narrow place round which
pits are dug and these being covered
with the little earth scattered over
hurdles the male elephant
easily falls into the snare in
copulation Johnson sees the belief that
it was important to get sex into as many
definitions as possible to lure in as
many readers like Hammond in a
copulation the female receives the mail
lying upon her back
I don't think so somehow the idea of a
female elephant dentally lying on her
back while 20 tons of engorged jumbo
comes down on her beggars belief
but he continues but such is his peu
DISA tee and here he breaches a cardinal
rule of lexicography that you never
include in a definition a word more
complicated and unusual than the word
you are attempting to define and I think
few in this audience well this is Yale
may be modest proportion in this
audience will know what pewdie City
means does anybody
well Sam Reuters pudendal it's that of
which we are ashamed such as his shyness
such as the elephants shyness that he
never covers the female so long as
anyone appears in sight
in other words Johnson never saw this
clearly made it all up this is why
Johnson's dictionary was wanting and
this is why the third of these important
dates is important and that's 1857 the
fifth of November 1857 Guy Fawkes Day in
London in the London library and the
Northwest societies in James's square
building which still exists played host
to the fill illogical society because by
this time the old habit of just taking
the English language for granted no one
really knew how much how big it was
massive it was it was rather like the
air we breathed we just as I say took it
for granted no one until Johnson really
felt
sorry to measure it and see what its
heft and extent was but philologists
beginning their business in the early
part of the 19th century took it upon
themselves to do just that and a man
called Richard Jena Vic's trench the
Dean of Westminster many of these people
were Divine's was a prominent figure in
the fill illogical society and had
indeed set up what was called the
unregistered words committee which is a
group that met in London every month to
look at words which they found while
trawling through documents books
journals that were not registered in the
dictionary in Johnson's dictionary and
so enormous was this number of
unregistered words but on this 5th of
November day in 1857
chené of exchange convened a meeting of
the fill illogical Society of London to
address them on some deficiencies in our
English dictionaries and he examined all
the extant dictionaries of the time and
said we need we are after all Victorians
who can do anything we master the seas
we can put up structures of any size we
can conquer a quarter of the world at
will we can surely master the entirety
of the language which is after all the
language that is going to be so he was
confident that it would be the dominant
language on the planet
so let us gentlemen they were all
gentlemen gird our loins and between
hardcovers assemble every single word in
the English language and let us and this
is an important thing let us not do what
the French and the Italians were doing
which is insist ex cathedra on what
these words should mean let us
illustrate from their usage in history
what these words actually do mean so to
collect all these words and to show the
twists and turns of their meanings over
the years we will have gentlemen to read
everything that's ever been written
but do not worry he said I have come up
with a plan on how to do this we will
assemble from throughout the in all of
the english-speaking world and this
isn't doesn't just me in England
Scotland Ireland and Wales but Indians
Australia New Zealand Canada the
Americas India South Africa volunteers
who will read everything and that's how
it essentially began a long and
convoluted process but the idea of
asking these volunteers to read
assiduously and on cards all of the
standard size six by four I think it was
in those early days right the catch word
that they were interested in and the top
left hand side and provide a quotation
that illustrated the meaning with a date
and the book or magazine or journal or
newspaper in which they found it they
were sent initially to London where
their dictionaries was it
first of all edited by Herbert Coleridge
the grandson of the poet he
optimistically built a set of pigeon
holes which still exist and can be seen
at Oxford University Press that he
thought would house all the slips with
all the references to all the words that
all these people were reading from all
over the world pigeon holes were nine
pigeon holes long six pigeon holes deep
54 vision holes he thought should do the
entirety of the English language and the
project might last a decade well it took
70 years and forth from these final of
these dates is after James Murray took
over there was a extraordinarily
eccentric man called Frederick furnivall
who took over from Coleridge because he
only lasted a year expiring having said
I must must what's good now I must begin
the Sanskrit tomorrow and then expired
then furnivall took over what was a
complete shambles because all he really
was interested in was taking large
breasted ladies sculling on the Thames
and but he was a brilliant lexicographer
and then James Merrill took over the
great hero who devoted the rest of his
life until he died in 1915 by which time
the dictionary was close to completion
and their 1928 the event we're
celebrating here today it was completed
in 12 volumes they had expected it would
initially take four but the twelve
volumes encompassed a language that
Johnson had included in his two volumes
40,000 words the first edition of the
OED
four hundred and fourteen thousand words
language immensely bigger than anyone
could conceivably imagine back in the
18th century supplement produced in 1933
for more supplements in the 1970 than a
complete new edition in the 1980s the
current second edition 20 volumes and
now of course online and going on to the
third edition which if it ever is
produced is going to be I think in now
June 204 7 is it a long time from now
jesse probably won't wish to be drawn on
this but anyway those are the four
crucial dates I'm now going to hand it
over back to Fred and I think then time
on to talk about the modern LED thank
you very much
Thank You Simon Ammann will be our next
speaker I'd like to start off with a bit
of a non sequitur
is a medical disorder called pica in
which the sufferer has a tendency to eat
what are typically regarded as non-food
type things such as chalk dirt sand
things like that I think I most commonly
affects pregnant women and the reason
I'm bringing it up is because when when
I tell people that I read the the OED
for a year they seem to regard me as
though I have a kind of particularly
bookish form of pica
and a real kind of bewilderment that I
would choose to read something that
seems so inherently non readable to them
first question I usually get is why and
then he's generally followed up by
saying well what are you gonna read next
after which they often give me helpful
suggestions of what I could read next
such non narrative texts like the phone
book there's nothing like that and I
have to say that to me this is this kind
of saddens me a bit and it doesn't
saddened me that people think that I'm
odd because I'm more or less used to
that but what really does saddened me is
that people think of reading a
dictionary as a kind of literary
equivalent of eating a candle or
something that it's such a kind of
aberrant behavior to so many people they
think well why would you ever read a
dictionary some people do read them but
you know most people seem to think it's
really kind of a strange thing to do and
to me it says a lot about how we tend to
look at dictionaries and in a certain
sense I feel like they've ceased to be
books and they are more looked at as
tools for many of us and this was for a
long time my my view towards the
dictionary was there was a book that I
would only go to when I was in trouble
it was never a book that I went to
for the enjoyment of it I would look at
a dictionary when I didn't know
something or when I wanted to prove
somebody else wrong or when I needed to
find something out specifically I
wouldn't really browse the dictionary
when I was very young and I have to say
I think that we're in viewing
dictionaries in this way we're kind of
performing a disservice to the the
dictionaries themselves to the the
lexicographers they compile them and
most of all to ourselves as readers that
we do not typically take full advantage
of this what the dictionary kind of has
to offer us and as was mentioned earlier
by Fred I've been reading dictionary
since I was a relatively small child and
I didn't start reading them really all
the way through cover to cover until
about 12 years ago and I have to say
that without a doubt I became hooked on
dictionaries as soon as I really started
reading them and I realized that perhaps
not everybody will share this viewpoint
of mine but they are really wonderful
intoxicated things to read I find that
everything that you would normally find
in a wonderful work of literature you
will find in a dictionary you just
happen to find it in a different order
than you're used to and you know people
usually regard me a little skeptically
when I say things like you know there's
all this great emotion in the dictionary
and well how can a reference work the
emotional in that sense and particularly
for a work like the Oxford English
Dictionary I found that when I read a
word like desiderio which means a thing
which you no longer have but wish that
you did it's impossible for me to read
that word in this definition without it
evoking in me something that I myself no
longer have and wish that I did or a
word like reward which can mean either a
touch of remorse our to remember
something with remorse it's impossible
for me to read that word without
thinking about something about which I'm
remorseful so the fact that these words
just exist and are pointed out to me and
these concepts exist and are pointed out
to me draws forth from me these emotions
so it's a kind of indirect way of
getting these emotions from the book but
it's very real nonetheless
and there's also a lot of humor I find
in the dictionary I'll be it usually of
a kind of unintentional sort but for
instance when when reading the OED and
you come across a word like unbe piste
which literally refers to the state of
not having been urinated upon I finally
really have to kind of stop and scratch
my head and wonder when was this a
necessary word the OED is kind of
wonderful dictionary for things like
that that's full of them the first
dictionary that I ever read cover to
cover was Webster's Merriam Webster's
second international which was published
in 1934 it's a wonderful little book
it's full of all kinds of useless things
like hundreds of Eastern gear and shrubs
that nobody really talks about anymore
and all kinds of erotic terms and stuff
like that but it was an intoxicating
experience I did not remember almost
anything of what I read but it was it
was really kind of captivating to me to
know that I hadn't missed anything in
this dictionary I used to go look up
words in the dictionary when I found a
word that I particularly enjoyed it was
quite pleasant but I was constantly
nagged by this feeling that there must
be other words that I haven't found that
I haven't seen it all never find them
and that is easily solved if you have a
considerable amount of time on your hand
by just reading all the way through and
as I said it was so intoxicating to me
that I went out and I read the sequel
which is Webster's theory then which was
not quite a smash hit as though the
second had been which is also a really
great dictionary and that was what
really got me more than anything else
kind of addicted to this this thing of
reading dictionaries because even though
it was published only 27 years later it
was truly remarkable to me to see how
much the language had changed in that
period of time see how different the
story was it was being told about our
language and also you know to see how
the lexicographers had treated the
corpus differently it was amazing to see
what words had fallen out what words
would come in how the words were treated
differently had changed about the
definition would have changed about the
scholarship it's every dictionary is in
some way different and as I said they're
really all telling the same story but
they're telling in their own inimitable
fashion and it always reminds me of a a
few years ago in a New York Times and
this wonderful article I think was when
a new translation of the Odyssey had
just been released and they reprinted
the first two paragraphs from six
different translations of the Odyssey
and by fagles and Richmond Latimore and
Robert Fitzgerald and they were all
substantially different from each other
and in so many ways it was really kind
of again captivating to see how the same
thing could be said different ways
depending on how you looked at it and to
me all dictionaries I really like this
even if they're written at a similar
time they're they're approaching things
in a different fashion and as Simon
mentioned it's it's you know a
relatively modern invention and so you
can you can really kind of trace the
history of English lexicography much
much more easily than you might imagine
and see how radically they've changed
just a few hundred years so as I said
I've been reading dictionaries for the
last 12 years or so and given that I had
read several Webster's and a number of
other different types of dictionaries
the Oxford English Dictionary was a
really kind of logical step for me to
take if you interpret logical as having
a lot of time in their hands and not
much of a social life
it certainly applies to me and so I quit
my job and I decided to take off the
year and read the OED which I've been
really kind of dreaming of going for
years and I have to say it was an
absolute joy it is unquestionably the
greatest story I have ever read and it
was the funniest thing I've ever read at
times the saddest thing I've ever read
and certainly the most informative and
having had read dictionaries before I
found that there were certain portions
that I would look forward to there were
certain prefixes that I remembered
fondly there were certain prefixes that
I really dreaded un goes for about 451
pages and it is almost entirely made up
of self-explanatory words it's not even
really defined it's really just a long
list it's incredibly unspeakably boring
coming from me that means something
substantial substantial boring and it
was very very tempting at that point to
kind of skip ahead when you see this
another 400 odd pages of this however I
realized that at some point if I had
skipped past the rest of the
self-explanatory words in you and there
are these wonderful words tucked in
there like uh nastiness which means
being equal to each other in stupidity
our words like the inexplicably obscure
unloved which simply means to stop
loving somebody which I cannot quite
understand how this word has ever fallen
out of fashion given that it is almost
as common as to fall in love with
somebody you know one of the things I
think we'll hear a lot about from Jessie
is you know what makes the OED so
special and what what makes it the
dictionary that it is and for me it's
one of the things that makes it so
readable a book and it it's just so full
of the actual literature of the English
language there are so many citations of
how the words have been used and see
it's not a dry vide
it's a little dry in some places but
it's really not as dry as you might
imagine it to be it's probably the only
book in the world that I can think of in
which Charles Bukowski and the courser
Mundi are both referenced within the
same
they take everything within the English
language that it's possible to date and
showcase how it's been used and you know
Simon was talking about the the history
not just a dictionaries in general but
the OED then it's something else it's a
real joy about reading the Oxford
English Dictionary is that it's history
is kind of rich so largely in his own
pages it's so much been a work in
progress for you know well over a
hundred years now and it's such an
enormous task that they have attempted
that it moves at a relatively slow pace
so as as Jesse will doubtless tell us
it's now being edited for the first time
from top to bottom
so what's great about that if you come
across entries that were written well
over a hundred years ago and haven't
changed and some of them are just so
inexplicable and strange and remember
either the word Muir annoyed was defined
as resembling the mouse are his allies I
had another one of those head-scratching
moments we just wonder is this an
obscure reference to the Nutcracker or
who are the Mouse's allies and it turns
out that Ally is actually a itself a
kind of archaic taxonomic term and
they've changed that definition now so
that that one got knocked out and it's a
little more up to date but you can also
see the personality of a lot of
lexicographers in there James and Marie
in particular the real gaiden force
behind the dictionary I feel like his
personality is somewhat more apparent
than many others and a lot of times he's
testes cantankerous he's always
incredibly erudite and he's on occasion
just plain odd for instance Sunday the
adverb cannily under a single entry he
defined it as slyly sagaciously
softly skillfully comfortably cautiously
prudently gently and then he tacked on
etc at the end just in case you want to
make up some definition of your own I
guess so these are all things that
really make it as I said you know far
more interesting to read than say the
phone book or something like that but
for me what really drew me in more than
anything else with the Oxford English
Dictionary was the fact that they're
looking at again the entirety
my language and that there are these
wonderful words to describe things that
we may I
I knew existed I never knew there's a
word for that and personally I am NOT in
favor of people using big words I find
it very irritating I cannot stand when I
just don't like reading
writers who use big words for their own
sake I love the vocabulary and I love
what the words mean but I try very hard
to not take these big words out of my
pocket and start swinging them around
but just the fact that they exist on
their own is something that I find
utterly delightful and it was
enrapturing to me to go through the
dictionary and find that there was a
word for this nameless thing that I
always thought should be named the fact
that there's a word for the smell of the
rain when it first starts falling on the
ground
petrichor is absolutely delightful
because now when the rain starts falling
I pay more attention to the smell that
it makes the fact that our language is
so specific that we have a word such as
a vigil as' which means somewhat greedy
as opposed to I guess exceptional
ingredient normally greedy
I think that's an absolute delight then
the fact that our language is even more
specific that we have words for a
satisfying meal which is boof Bosh and
we also have words for a great meal
which is grandma's air is absolutely
spectacular and now I can distinguish
between a satisfying meal and a great
meal if only in my head and also wanted
to mention another one of a kind of
delightfully odd moments in the Oxford
English Dictionary is under the
definition of Brahmas er a great meal
there's an editor's note that says not
from the original French which has do
you think you can eat all the pagans by
yourself and I haven't found that
anybody at Oxford and will explain that
to me yeah
again these are not words that I usually
would use in casual conversation but the
fact that these things exist and I know
the word for them is it enables me to
pay more attention to them so the words
are not themselves useless you know the
fact that there's a word on dissonant
which describes the sound of the waves
make when they crash on the shore now
the fact that there's a word sitter ISM
which describes the sound that the wind
makes one of Russell's the leaves of the
fact that there's a word oppressor T
which describes the warmth of the Sun in
wintertime these are things that I find
again again and again I keep saying
enrapturing I pay more attention to
these things just in my own head the
fact that one is starting to change from
late afternoon to early evening I can
say to myself but it's at vesper ating
is something that I always find
interesting
in conclusion I would just say that at
the beginning we heard that the fred
said that the Oxford English Dictionary
was the greatest humanistic research
project in the world and it
unquestionably is it's it's a this
massive amount of scholarship it's just
you know you can't help but be in awe of
what they've accomplished but it is also
above and beyond that just simply a
great read thank you
maybe dogs and mice are allies on the
theory that the enemy of my enemy is my
friend
thank you I mache and again his book is
reading the OED we're gonna move on into
a moderate question answer and this is
gonna be focused on Jessie rather than
his giving a presentation he's going to
talk about the revision of the OED and I
I may interject some questions but just
if you want you can sit down there or
come up here he'll talk about the
current edition of the OED which is
being completely revised now it's the
main thing about the OED that hasn't
been mentioned in detail yet is the fact
that the OED is what is called a
historical dictionary so when we learned
that the second edition of the OED which
came out in 1989 is 20 volumes long it's
not that large because it has 20 times
more words than a one volume dictionary
in fact the OED
doesn't have as many words as Webster's
second which Amman read that dictionary
had about from 1934 had about six
hundred thousand words defined and OAD
to only had about four hundred fifty
thousand what makes the OED special and
what makes it different from most other
dictionaries is that it is historical
meaning that for every sense of every
word in the dictionary it is illustrated
by quotations that are taken from
literature
showing how these words have been used
so the examples that all these
volunteers that Simon mentioned that
they send in to increasingly larger
series of pigeon holes weren't just
theirs that the editors could look at
them and decide how to define a word
they were there because they they
provide the core of the entry itself so
when you look out the word that has been
in the language since the 15th century
you will find
five or 10 or 15 examples from authors
who have used that word so you can see
how Shakespeare used it how Byron used
it how Dickens used it how John Updike
used it and get a sense of how long this
word has been around where it has been
used in what in what countries
what kind of authors used it if it's
only used in formal texts or informal
texts or slang sources so by looking at
these things you can get a real sense of
how the language actually works and not
just be told that this is what the
definition is this is what the
pronunciation is so that's what makes
the OED special and but also what also
makes it so large the problem is when
you have a dictionary of this size and
this scope revising it is a difficult
task now the second edition of the OED
despite its name is not really a new
edition what the second edition did was
to take the first edition of the OED
from 1928 and take the supplements that
Robert Burke field had published in the
1970s and 80s and combined them into a
single coherent text but entries that
existed in OED 1 were not changed so if
you looked at a word that has been in
language for a few hundred years the
odds are extremely good that the
definition is completely untouched and
that the last quotation is from the
1890s or 1900's or something so people
looking at that the allegedly modern you
know Edie - in fact are seeing a book
that's almost entirely a hundred years
old at this point
so what's necessary to do then is to
rise the entire dictionary which is a
very very long prospect which we've been
doing for a few years now the groundwork
for this was begun in the 1990s after
the supplements were published well they
work on OED too in 1989 and then started
thinking well okay time to think about
what we're going to do next and we have
to revise it all and preliminary work
was done throughout the 90s and in 2000
we began publishing Oh a d3 online
we began with the letter M when people
asked why we usually say well that way
we get to Z faster but the real reason
is that it's typical of course to begin
dictionary at the letter A and when you
begin it especially something like the
OED which was so different from
dictionaries that came beforehand you
don't really know what you're doing and
the editorial standards change and you
approach things in different ways and
you learn what you're doing and the same
thing happened with the supplements
supplements began publishing a and
finished with Z the way you do so if you
look at OAD 2 now the differences in
editorial style and quality between a
and B and let's say M or are are quite
significant and since we are also
starting a major project of our own with
staff who most of whom hadn't done this
kind of work before and having to cover
a lot of ground and do a lot of new
things we thought it would make more
sense to start at M where a a reasonable
level of editorial stability had been
reached than to start with the
relatively new staff and new editorial
ideas with the somewhat rougher material
that he finds an a and B so in 2000 we
began publishing in M and most recently
we've started we have published the
first parts of our online so we've gone
m n o P Q which is minuscule and
starting R now in those 8 years we don't
actually have a date an exact date for
when we're going to be finishing we
there are various things we do say like
oh yes 10 years 7 years 15 years but in
fact we don't really know it will be a
long time and we are getting faster and
faster all the time computers by the way
don't actually make the work faster or
we are very highly computerized now and
have been since the well for quite some
time but in fact having access to all
these electronic resources makes it
rather slower work in the old days you
would have a file box with the slips you
were working on still four by six
slurps and if you didn't find what you
needed in there you could do a little
bit of additional research you could
send someone to the library but pretty
much what you had in the in the file was
what you had to deal with and you had to
make do now you can sit you know anyone
can sit in front of any computer and
have you know pretty much every example
you know that's ever been written of a
particular word if you don't care to
look that hard so instead of having five
examples of illustrating how the word
European was used in the 18th century
let's say you could now have you know
12,000 examples and if you uh you know
try looking at them you'll go mad it
does take a long time to do these things
when the the middle English dictionary
which is a sister project which was
completed a few years ago covering just
the English for the middle English
period was being worked on my colleague
Joe Pickett who's now the chief editor
of the American Heritage Dictionary was
working on the entry talkin which is the
Middle English word for take and was
expected to take two years to complete
this one word and when he finished it in
six months there was mass astonishment
and envy and admiration of how good a
job he had he had done on this one word
so right now we're estimating that when
the dictionary is complete it will be
about 40 volumes long the equivalent of
40 volumes so though we're not sure if
we will publish it in print form many of
us hope we do but it's too early to say
at this point what the market is going
to be and you know 10 or 20 years let's
say for a 40 volume print dictionary
when probably most people will still
want to look at it online in the
original OED the most the longest entry
was for the word set set Missy T and
James Murray it always seemed to me must
have done one of the greatest
intellectual feats in history just to
organize thousands and thousands of
citations into hundreds and hundreds of
census is one person going to be
assigned randomly the alphabetical job
of revising the word said and having to
rethink
everything that Murray did it won't be
randomly assigned but you know it will
be an extremely experienced person it is
a very difficult job and working on
words at that scope are many people work
on a typical entry even an entry that
would be relatively straightforward
let's say some a new word where the
meaning is relatively clear the history
is relatively clear would still get
looked at by a number of people you'd
have a relatively junior editor who
would do the initial drafting and then a
more senior editor would look it over
and make some comments and if it's a
newer the head of the new words group
would look it over and and approve it
and then the chief editor or the deputy
chief editor would make the final
adjustments to it and an entry of this
something like set or of that scope
would have many more people involved of
course because you would have a large
number of researchers looking at looking
for additional evidence or earlier
evidence for the census you would have a
number of editors doing preliminary
drafting work or moving it around
dividing it in different ways and
eventually there would be one quite
senior editor who would do a lot of work
and making sure that the whole thing is
coherent and no the chief editors would
would have the final say on it set was
the longest entry in OED one and OED two
but now since we're well since we're
publishing as we go there are longer
entries when we first a soon after we
started the word make took over as the
longest entry in the OED and now the
word put is the longest entry and in
another a couple of years the word run
will very likely be the longest entry
and OED but I think it's quite likely
that when we come back back around to it
Seth will once again take over the pride
of place as the longest entry I think
take was the longest in Johnson was yeah
take was long as it was 14 and I like
the fact that when furnivall was dying
Murray they were working on teeth and
furnivall wrote in and said ah I've got
another six months to live and Murray
said well would you in that case while
you're on your deathbed
care to look at take now that we've
almost finished and he did and completed
take a good final task one of the things
about Johnson by the way Johnson's
dictionary was extremely great there was
almost nothing or perhaps even nothing
in it that had never actually been seen
before there were there was nothing
innovative in it in the strictest sense
but what was innovative was how good it
was if you look at any earlier
dictionary you will find you can find
things that Johnson did but never as
good and just for comparison the the
best dictionary that came slightly
before Nathan Bailey's dictionary which
came out and well there's different
versions but let's say 1731 the entry
for taking that was 300 words long the
entire entry for take the entry in
Johnson was 8,000 and had 114 different
sub senses so you would have earlier
dictionaries that did divide words into
into meanings but nothing like what you
saw in Johnson and you know he was
really getting this from nowhere I mean
well through the brilliance of his mind
you know was able to look at these words
and come up with these extremely
comprehensive sense divisions that
really hadn't ever been seen before it
was really a remarkable undertaking just
could you talk a little bit about your
use of the OED use of online databases
and is that is that something that makes
it harder now whereas there are now
conceivably dozens of online databases
that could shed light on when a word was
first used where do you draw the line as
to what to check and what not to check
well it's an extremely difficult process
I mean it takes it takes a very long
time as I said before to use all these
resources you can't look at everything
even if you have access to it you can't
look in all the databases that you have
access to you can't look at all the
words that you find in them so depending
on what kind of word is how
it is what uh you know what genre it's
and what know what kind of people were
using it you will look at different
sources if you have an older word you
look at something like ebo the early
english books online which is books from
before the 18th century english printed
books if you have 18th century stuff you
have echo the 18th century collections
online if you're looking at more recent
things in the newspapers let's say you
look at different versions of the
ProQuest historical newspapers database
newspaper archive you can look at google
books but there are dozens or hundreds
of databases that you can use so if
you're interested in if you're coming up
with something well from the Civil War
there are databases of civil war letters
you know just that there are databases
of African American drama now there are
databases of golf magazines and you know
these are highly specialized and you're
not going to look at them most of the
time and most of time you won't even
remember that they're there but the one
time you are working on a golfing term
and do remember will wait there isn't
there this full-text database of golfing
magazines and you know all of a sudden
you're finding you know great
discoveries and all sorts of wonderful
things what we will typically do is we
have a list of let's say one or two
dozen databases that we will very
regularly use that for you know almost
any entry will get looked at even if
it's a new entry we would look at it in
all of these databases and then there
are additional ones which editors can
use or researchers can use if they think
it might be helpful but again you can't
look at everything so it's quite
possible that in many cases someone else
can come along and look at a new
database and discover something that
we've missed or for that matter look at
a database that we have used and find
something that we've missed because most
of the time it's very difficult getting
the kind of information out of these
databases that that you can get out it's
one thing if you have a new word and
you're searching for a particular form
and all you have to do is type that form
and you will find it I mean let's forget
even about spelling variations but if
you were looking for
you know word from the last couple of
centuries you can be reasonably
confident that you know you type in that
spelling and you will find that but if
you're trying to find different senses
that can be very difficult to do in a
database and the one I like to use for
an example is though the so called Gen X
so which is the use of so to modify
words that are typically not modifiable
so the classical example from the movie
heathers obly mia that's so 1987 or you
know we are so not going to have a good
time at this party things like this you
know this is a relatively new use but
you can't find this in a database
without because you just can't look at
all the examples of so there are just
too many so the things you do is well
try to think of some kind of frame in
which this is likely to appear you know
yes you can search for so 1987 so in
1988 so 1989 and so forth
you know some of the things that you
will find will be this sense but you
can't predict everything so someone can
come along and five I think of a better
way to search for this and find a better
example or you just can't find an
example I mean there there are things
that you are not going to be able to
find in database isn't because it's too
hard to search for them this way and one
of the things about the OED now that's
very different from the way it always
has been in the past is that of the
reading program the effort of getting
volunteers or freelancers to read
through a wide variety of sources and
you know send in interesting examples
for words is no longer the most
important part of the way we work it is
no longer what we use to define from we
still do get a lot of examples from the
reading program and the reading programs
are very active but most of the examples
now we are getting from full text
databases so it very much changes how we
work so the but but it words such as
these like Gen X so or other things like
that or what you do want your your
readers to be able to find no one's
going to find them if you don't find
them that way but it's a big opportunity
now for people
well no longer do you have to have 15
million 4x6 slips of paper in your files
in Oxford in order to write it right
this dictionary
anyone who's at a university or you know
institution or a large library has
access to the same databases that we do
so you no longer need to have some
special thing that no one else has
access to anyone could do the OED anyone
can contribute and you know we think
this is great I mean we're not worried
that someone else is going to have you
know another project which is just like
the OED but different but it's very
useful that people can contribute in
this way you know someone with an
interest in some particular field will
you know can do research that we just
don't have the time to do because there
only so many hours in the day so you
know someone who knows that there is a
database of 18th century coal mining
terms you know can send in examples that
we didn't know to find and nessa
you know it's very helpful to us it's a
good thing what is and what is the
purpose of the British national corpus
on the British national corpus is one of
a number of corporate that were set up
corpora are basically very large
collections of of language that you can
use for various linguistic purposes the
earliest important corporate was the
brown corpus the corpus suit was the
brown corpus from the mid 1960s which
was of course of assembled by hand and
then computerized and it had a million
words and what you typically do with the
corpus is tag it up in various ways to
illustrate parts of speech or the kind
of you know kind of source formal
informal what country it's from and you
can look at it in a systematic way and
get a sense for example of word
frequencies you know how common are
these words how common are these words
and Caucasians you know appearing with
other words
in particular contexts and the larger
your corpus is the more you can say if
you have the right tools to analyze it
nowadays it's trivial to come up with
extremely large corpora the British
national corpus was assembled in the
1980s and a hundred thousand words is
that right you know it was very large
and it was a systemically derived corpus
the the problem with all of the with
getting a good corpus is not just
randomly choosing a bunch of words
because they're a bunch of texts because
they're easily available so you could
very easily get a corpus of let's say
legal texts because these have been
available in electronic form for a long
time it's harder to get a large body of
evidence of slang or drama let's say
just because these are not things that
are typically been digitized although
now that's changing everything is out
there so you don't just want to assemble
a hundred 200 million words that you
could find pretty easily you want to
assemble a relatively balanced a number
of sources so that when you're looking
at something you're getting as well as
close as you can get to a balanced
picture of the whole language so what
you do with the BMC or any other corpus
is will analyze it in this way so you
can you know use various tool various
tools to look at it statistically to
compare you know word frequent
frequencies usage studies the we have a
corpus now the oxford corpus which we
developed in-house which now has I think
two or three billion words and which we
drive mainly from online sources
although again trying to get as wide a
range as possible and you know you can
look at this in different ways you can
look at all the English things you can
look at all the New Zealand things you
can get all the blog entries you can get
all the scientific sources but when you
look at a corpus you can get very
interesting ideas about how the language
is actually used in a way that you can't
even by looking at quotations because
you're making you're able to use
evidence for many many more words
and see things that you can't find by
looking at them one by one you know is
this word typically used in a negative
or positive way even if you might not
have realized this is this word
typically used with other words you know
how is it used with this kind of adverb
and make interesting discoveries that
you couldn't otherwise make now the OED
tends not to make as much use of
corporis other dictionaries corpora are
more useful for four well because the
OED is historical we're looking for
other things than many other things than
the sort of things you can get out of a
corpus so the trade dictionaries at
Oxford know the one-volume dictionaries
and especially the bilingual
dictionaries where these kinda see the
usage issues and being able to explain
them is more of an emphasis than than
what we do they use the oxford corpus
more but in general that's the purpose
of corpora or to be able to look at
language in this way that you can't buy
one by one analysis of words we should
give an opportunity for people in the
audience to ask questions Thank You
Jessie
let me just mention as someone who was a
leading contributor to the OED in the
old days of looking at books for word
usages and then became an exponent of
using online databases it's it's
actually taken a lot of the fun out of
being a no IDI contributor it used to be
the great excitement as an OED
contributor was picking a book off of
the shelf and opening it to exactly the
right page to find that an anti dating
of a first use of a word and that
happens if you if you do this kind of
thing now you feel it's really it's not
your own talents I mean you have to may
have talents as a database searcher but
it's not your own talent so much as its
the abilities of the database that's at
play here so it's actually kind of not
as fun as it used to be to be a
contributor aren't there any questions
that anyone has if you want to ask
questions we would love that for any of
our
panelists come up to the microphone are
there words that have identical meanings
to different words and if not or if so
when you come across words that have
very close meanings in which is a very
fine distinction between them and this
difference is about the difference
what's the process whereby you make a
decision about I guess what definition
goes in and what doesn't
use that as a criterion for whether or
not to keep something hand
there's already word
that
I wanted to reassure I'm in Shae on
unlove if I remember correctly the
earlier sites included Chaucer's from
Troilus and Cressida something like I
cannot find it in my heart too unloving
you a quarter of a day and then we go to
two Jane Eyre I had learned to love mr.
Rochester I could not unlove him now but
then we have country songs by the by the
at least half dozen of the form how can
i unloved you so it's it's alive and
well we don't have to worry about
wasn't there a song a few years ago
unbreak my heart why these tears yeah
liebe citing that song I was fortunate
enough to work as a lexicographer for
the Oxford American dictionaries project
for a few years in the 1990s one of the
things I learned in that job was how
hard it is to get a word out of a
dictionary once it's gone in given that
the OED is a historical dictionary I
wonder if you do try to get words out or
if you like to leave them in for
historical reasons if you do try to take
them out how do you what are the
criteria you use
dictionaries purpose is about just show
the words that we are using now show the
words that ever have been in English so
we have words in there that have nothing
but century have perfectly fine it means
that when we are deciding what within we
have to be very careful because we can't
just trade dictionary say well let's
toss it all these words we could use it
for marketing and then take about when
if you don't need them anymore we don't
have that for good which doesn't mean
that tough global terms should not go in
just something extremely common
and that is a problem time so you do
have increase where well where you look
at something - what on earth will they
think why further ways but now we're
revising they have somewhere the
principal thing and but you're stuck
with that you have to do we're putting
off her cell phone
likely to trip over
out there and it would be the sort of
thing that we would never put in now but
because it is in I am unfortunately
stuck leaving it there and you know
writing a new definition for and all of
that I might add that I came over from
London this morning and I wish I brought
the papers with me because they are full
of the controversy that is gripping the
country at the moment which is Collins
dictionaries decision to retire about a
hundred and fifty words I think and
people crossword puzzle addicts of which
there are many in Britain are outraged
and will I dare say in their millions
switch as they should to Oxford couple
of decades on world Englishes I'm
interested to know to what extent the
OED wants to continue distinguishing the
use of words in how many different
varieties of English well in all of them
if we have the evidence no the OED has
always been interested in world English
now we have the tools for studying this
better and in particular we have many
other national dictionaries that cover
English's of various other countries so
you have the dictionary of New Zealand
even if you have the dictionary of
Australian English you have the
dictionary here if you're lucky enough
to be interested in scoffs you have not
only the 12 volume dictionary the older
Scottish song which covers Scots up to
1800 but you have the 10 volume Scottish
national dictionary which covers Scots
after 1800 so for most national
varieties there are and many regional
varieties as well and there are existing
historical dictionaries that we can use
as a basis so in the dictionary of
Newfoundland English there's a
dictionary Prince Edward Island English
there is a Canadian historical
dictionary that's currently being
revised now so there are a lot of things
like this that you could use one of the
things we're also doing in the and one
of the things that I predicted in
particularly spend a lot of time working
on for the original edition of the OED
word that were from some other country
were labeled with us so if you had a
word that was on the use in Australia
would say Australia had a word that was
used in America would say US or if it's
North America it was in Canada too you
would have been a mayor of something
like that if you had a word that was
used everywhere it would have no label
of course but if you had a word that was
used only in England it would also have
no label words that were not English
were labeled with words that were only
English were not labeled so one of the
things we're doing now is making sure
that words that are only British have a
British label which is something that's
not always easy for a British editor to
determine so one of the things I do is
go through and make sure that British
entries have British labels was it an
important moment when Oxford issued no
add a new Oxford American Dictionary
because it didn't say American English
Dictionary it sort of was a formal
acknowledgement on the jacket that the
language that you speak here is American
rather than American English well there
actually there was a lot of controversy
about how to refer to American English
and there have been dictionaries that
have been criticized for you know having
American in their title when they are in
fact not dictionaries of American you
know but dictionaries of American
English so in fact a camera which review
was but it but a dictionary the
historical dictionary of American slang
was criticized by one reviewer because
it was not it did not include Spanish
slang that was used in America or
you know this slang of other in Native
American languages it was only American
English so you know having American near
of standing for American English is
something that people do notice any
other question hi I sort of have a
question I guess about the nature of
citations within the OED and I guess
what the criteria for those are and
whether it's changed at all over the
years because I've just started looking
at Johnson's dictionary and I think he
even says at the beginning he you know
seeks to illustrate the different
significations by examples from the best
writers it tends to be like you know
Dryden Spenser Shakespeare Milton the
same five people so I was wondering
whether that has changed it all for the
OED especially with the advent and the
use of the internet and sort of as a
related question whether or not you've
looked at urbandictionary.com and what
you think of it for those who don't know
it's sort of like a Wikipedia of slang
and other sources about nature Johnson
was specifically interested in
illustrating there were about a hundred
thousand illustrative citations in
Johnson which fully a third works on
shakespeare Dryden or Milton which not
only well which helps to submit their
reputations as well as provide tons of
examples in Johnson um the OED has
always been interested in the much wider
net than just the quote unquote best
authors there's a belief that the OED is
only is very formal or only interested
in literary English and this is not true
and never has been but it's certainly
true that in the earlier years it was
more true than
then what has happened since but now we
are interested in general in getting as
wide a range as we can the problem is
you have a very limited amount of space
and you have a very large number of
things you're trying to do with the
quotation paragraph so if you have
something that goes some well a word
where you want to have 10 examples let's
say you have many many many different
things you're trying to do first of all
you have to cover geographical rather a
chronological spread more or less evenly
so you can't have one example from 1690
then 10 things from the 1980s you have
to have examples from different
countries if it's being used in those
countries you want have examples from
authors if it's not a formal word or not
a slang word or not a technical or you
want have examples from formal and
technical and slang sources showing that
the word is used in these different ways
you want have examples from male and
female authors you want have examples
from educated and less educated authors
and so forth and and you're trying to do
all these things at the same time and
you want all of your examples to be good
ones that really show how the word is
being used the famous example of how not
to choose a quotation was the example
that William Craigie I think chose a
railway Porter which was in full he was
a railway former James Murray wrote a
scathing note to him not note a letter
going on four pages about what an
idiotic choice this one
so you have to have examples where the
railway Porter took his ticket and moved
on to the next person or something like
that that actually shows how this is
being used and these aren't always
available you can't get all of these
things done at the same time so trying
to choose your quotations is a very
difficult task it was then when you only
had slip files but it still is now that
you have all these databases available
yeah but they urban dictionary
general population well I in fact do
think that the urban dictionaries have
extremely low quality time I think it's
a very very very useful source
partly because it is a low-quality one
of the young no no I'm being completely
serious I'm one of the things that be
very important if you have dictionaries
of slang or dictionaries of technical
terms or particular fields is that you
want them to be as little touched by
people who think they are smart as
possible so a public dictionary of slang
we're through
publication process have been copy
edited and proof read and everyone's
changing
what they think it mean you're getting
something the end that may not be what
it really is because we were making
change that might not because / the
reality of it the Urban Dictionary and
other let's say self-published slang
dictionaries or you know high school no
one is taking there's no one who people
who compile slang dictionaries typically
take other slang dictionaries and you
know say well okay we've got to put in
all of these and you know we use their
definitions if it's something I haven't
heard of their definition was probably
right which means when you're looking at
it you're not getting you're not
necessarily getting something that's
really in use you're getting something
that people are copying from somewhere
or taking from somewhere else if you get
Miss so-and-so's eighth grade class
dictionary you can be pretty certain
that you're getting what they think
those words mean and that's very
important and very useful so the urban
dictionary i think is pretty lousy but
but if you know what you're doing it's a
very useful source because you can go
there and and you have people saying
well this is what this means in my place
or no it dozens and you know here's what
I think it means and you can use that I
mean this is primary source research all
gathered for you very nicely thumbs down
one thing about a how the OED maybe has
changed a bit in terms of getting these
words when I just wrote down on my way
over was a from the older version the
OED which is still in there the word
disrespect George Meredith and Beauchamp
Beauchamp career from 1876 the citation
is treating her like a disrespected
grandmother and then in the online
version now they have a quote from a
spoon eg a spooning wrap which is from
nineteen eighty and he says you want to
be dissed and then you want to be a
crook you find an old lady take a
pocketbook and I think it was either
Jesse or Ben Zimmer who found that but
it's it was not until they actually
released a book a few years ago in which
somebody had actually transcribed rap
lyrics so you couldn't just say okay
well I heard this on the radio and I
know what
ssangsun already done actually come from
a source and in after having finished
finished reading though I've been
spending a lot of time really going back
and forth comparing the online version
with the print version and they are
doing a remarkable amount of work
updating it it's one of the great things
you can do with the online LEDs you can
look up a word in Oh ad 3 and then you
can compare it to the 1989 version by
just hitting a little button and you can
see exactly how much is changing and
it's again it's a really remarkable
difference between the citations
previous about how we use different
kinds of sources we still do the primacy
of print still holds the OED we do want
to have our examples in print sources
mainly for bibliographic reasons that
it's important that people can look
these up afterwards and they you know
dispute what we say the evidence is
there it's real you can find in the
resource library which you can't do if
you just record things that that someone
said it is the case now that so much is
happening online or song lyrics that may
not have been published but are
available in recorded versions let's say
that you want to be able to quote from
some of these which we are doing more
and more of as time goes on but it's
still something we're extremely careful
with and new bibliographic standards
haven't really evolved to the point
where we can reliably quote these the
way we would like so for rap songs I
mean yes there are times and we will
quote songs that are not that have not
been published in a book of rap lyrics
let's say we would much rather have them
in that form but we will do so necessary
we would it's a very rare although we do
do it in certain cases that we would
just quote from a website
mr. website floating out there not
website containing but we do do it at
times an example of how the citations
have improved and how also the pitfalls
of non book citations the OED supplement
that was published in the 1970s het for
the word jazz had as their first use a
1909 record and it was very rare for
them to cite from a record rather than a
printed source and it later was shown
that this I believe it was actually in
1919 citation a 1919 record so it was
not at all accurate as the first use of
the word and recent research by various
people using online databases has shown
a completely different story for the
origin of the word jazz than anyone
thought before it was always thought to
come from New Orleans and probably have
sexual connotations but in fact there's
clear evidence that it seems to have
originated in West Coast baseball
circles and the earliest citations are
from 1912 describing some kind of pitch
that been Henderson of the Portland
baseball team through Portland Oregon
baseball team that I guess it had a lot
of movement on it and they talked about
it as the jazz curve and so that's an
example where the tremendous
availability now of old newspaper and
book citations is transforming our
understanding of a lot of words rather
like there's one example of the pitfalls
involved in the modernizing of
definitions there's a word infrequently
used but I think it's a wonderful
portmanteau word which displays the
wonders of the English language is the
word malmö rocking which is mal le ma
are okay ing which is the
carousing of drunken seamen on ice bound
Greenland whaling ships and that that
was the original definition but the
refined contemporary definition has been
subtly changed it is malmö rocking the
carousing of drunken seamen on ice bound
whaling ships leaving out the world word
Greenland and this prompted one of the
editorial writers on the Guardian to
write on a Saturday morning when not
much was happening in the world
that he found this very alarming that
the practice of malmö rocking seemed to
have become unleashed from Greenland and
was spreading around the world this he
said must be stopped I think are there
any other questions yeah well we do
include a very large amount of technical
terms the fact that a term is technical
is not a reason for keeping it out I
mean what we go for in general is
currency of any word so whether it's a
technical term whether it's a you know
vulgar term whether it's racially
offensive whether it's considered on
grammatical the only thing that matters
is how much evidence we have for it so a
term won't be kept out because it's only
used in mathematics let's say what we
tried to do is for technical terms is
make as good a determination as we can
you know how prominent this really isn't
literature so something that's a
technical term only used in an extremely
narrow subfield where even people in
let's say professional mathematicians
wouldn't know this particular term
because it's only used in some very
narrow subfield of mathematics would be
unlikely to go in but a term that is
widely used even if it's highly
technical and only known to specialists
would would be likely to go in as would
a term that is primarily used in a
technical field but is something that is
known outside
even if let's say outside people don't
know fully what it means in this case
with a lot of medical terms and we do
have a science group who's devoted just
to this that everyone on there is a
trained scientist and several people
have PhDs in different disciplines who
go through these making sure that the
that this is covered correctly and that
two terms are belonging and we should
move on for those of you who are
interested there is a wine and cheese
reception at the Sterling library in the
lnb room they we have guides that can
show either way but basically if you're
not familiar with the area go down
College Street from here turn right on
Wall Street and you'll come to the very
large building the Sterling Law Library
and you enter from that sorry the
Sterling Memorial Library and you enter
from the buying two key plaza from where
the woman's table is the High Street
entrance and thank you very much to our
panelists